d'ouverture et accueillante pour changer
les choses à trinité nous ce qu'on veut
c'est amener le bien-être le mieux vivre
ensemble pour les trinitéens et c'est
vrai que nous sommes conscients du fait
que les subsides ont reculé la dotation
de l'état régresse donc il faudra tout
simplement être ingénieux pour aller
chercher les finances où elles sont
parce que en fait la réalité c'est qu'il
n'y a pas on dit qu'il n'ya pas d'argent
mais peut-être que il ya des pistes
qu'on n'a pas exploré peut-être qu'il
faut faire peut être encore mieux et
plus avec moins avec les idées des
hommes en se mettant ensemble
donc l'idée dans notre programme nous
nous caressons l'espoir de voir les
trinitéens se mettre ensemble pour faire
progresser cette trinité et mettre
l'humain carrément au centre de l'action
municipale